hello everyone Joey here and welcome
back to the second lesson of economics
where I'm gonna guide you through which
weapon to use in splatoon too now if you
haven't watched the first lesson on how
to move make sure you watch that first
and while you're at it you know consider
subscribe so you don't miss any other
videos like this one so weapons but too
there's a lot of them and I've broken
them up into seven different categories
and they are shooters blasters brawler's
Chargers brushes slashers and splat
lanes that's a lot to get through so
what I'll do here is have a quick
rundown of each type what they can do
and I'll also be giving my personal
preference of which weapon is my
favorite so let's take a quick look
alright so the first weapon category
we're gonna be talking about our
shooters now shooters are your basic
rapid-fire inking guns similar to say
assault rifle in another game but there
are a bunch of different shooters some
of them have longer range a wider ink
spread some have better damage but the
main purpose of them is to be kind of a
jack-of-all-trades with a good shooter
you'll be able to ink a lot of turf and
also get a lot of splats with it as well
so in order to do that you want to stay
moving as much as possible if you
haven't seen the first lesson of
economics where I teach you guys how to
move you can check that out on the
GameSpot YouTube channel but basically
you want to just keep moving like you're
never gonna be stopping and smelling the
roses you're always gonna be frantically
looking around finding a place to ink
seeing where the other team is and going
from I would say out of all the weapons
they're the ones that are probably the
most frantic and the ones that encourage
offense the most and so shooters as a
whole basically since they're so
versatile don't work with any sub weapon
in pretty much any special in the game
but personally I enjoy the fast inking
of the arrow spray mg it's a weapon that
has one of the best fire rates in the
game so you can ink turf get in and out
and really quickly move around the map
so if you can get in close and fast
against your opponents this is a weapon
that you'll have a hell of a time way
all right next up our blasters and
blasters are kind of the second cousins
to the shooter they're halfway between a
grenade launcher and a shotgun and so
what they'll do is shoot out a small
blob that explodes after a certain
distance and now these are a little bit
harder to use since they are slower and
they don't have the rapid-fire element
like the shooters do but they do have
the advantage of being able to hit
people around corners and so what you
want to do with them is kind of time
your shots maybe throw out a shot make
sure it hits and then back up try get
your second shot to splat them what
blasters are really good at though are
taking out groups of Inklings so anytime
you see people crowded together or if
there's a bunch of people on the tower
or splat zones you want to make sure you
have a blaster on hand to take out a
couple of them at a time now this is
more of a personal preference but I
really like blasters that have a huge
blast radius and a really short range so
I can get up close and splat them
immediately
now the first game had one called the
Luna blaster and it's in this game -
you'll have to wait till level 19 to
unlock it but trust me it's worth it
okay next up our rollers and rollers are
among one of the most unique weapons
you'll ever see in the shooter now their
main purpose is usually for inking as
they lay down the wide path of ink
wherever they walk but they have a lot
of power to them - because you can
remember to roll over anyone in one hit
these so that means you do have to be
close to them so what you want to do is
kind of hide in the ink sometimes and
then jump out and then splat them one
thing that you want to try to avoid
though is chasing people as you can be
kind of a sitting duck if you're trying
to run after someone like that also you
can jump an attack to fling ink in a now
vertical manner as opposed to the
horizontal way in the first mattoon and
what this does it helps you reach walls
to climb up and also help reach faraway
enemies and it also helps with the
rollers main weakness which is forward
momentum normally it was difficult for
rollers to escape since the ink that
they paint was always behind them but
now with the vertical flick you can
actually give a path to move forward
making it you know just as fast as other
weapons when you're trying to get from
one place to another and if you're just
starting out the standard splat roller
loadout is actually really good has the
curling bomb which helps you with your
4-momentum even more
and squash I will really really help you
when you're cornered alright next up
we're gonna be talking about brushes and
brushes are kind of similar to rollers
in that they leave a trail of ink
wherever you walk but they're
interesting for a couple different
reasons one because they grant you some
of the fastest movement speed while
using the weapon in the game like you
can make a path from your spawn to their
spawn in pretty much no time they also
have a very powerful melee attack at
point-blank range there aren't many
weapons that are better it's very
difficult to react to a surprise attack
with a brush and it also gives you a
pretty big spread of ink so if you get
to a high location you can just wipe it
around and spread ink all over the place
now so what you want to do with brushes
is kind of use it to your advantage use
the speed to your advantage
get into their territory early pop up
hit them with a brush run out you know
hit-and-run tactics are very very useful
with brushes but one thing that you want
to watch out for is ink usage because
they use a lot of ink and because of the
fact they leave such a narrow strip it's
going to be hard to find good patches of
ink to recharge your weapon with so if
you go up on the offensive you probably
need to be stealthy you know going up
against something like a shooter or a
slasher will probably cause you some
troubles but if you can sneak in and
splash some ink run away repeat pretty
much good to go alright next up are
chargers and charges are a splatoon's
version of the sniper rifle it's a very
powerful weapon and actually a personal
favorite of mine so shots what the
charger will travel really far compared
to any other weapon in the game and
they'll also lay down a lane of ink
behind it depending on how long you
actually hold the charge for and now
they may seem a little bit slow to use
that you can't really move too much
while actually aiming them but what they
do is they lay down that lane of ink a
really long way and then you can
actually use that Lane to swim so with
the charger you can actually travel
great distances really really quickly
and you want to incorporate your
vertical movement along with that they
only take one shot in order to paint an
entire wall so you can use it to climb
walls and reach high points and so from
up there you can snipe people and also
lay down lanes of ink that will help cut
the enemy off so since you are a sniper
pretty much if an enemy gets close to
you you'll want to immediately run away
you know use your sub weapon whatever
you got just try to create some distance
between you and the other inkling
because nine times out of ten you'll
probably lose in a firefight to a
shooter and also real quick one new
feature that they added for Chargers is
the ability to hold your charge while
swimming in the ink so if you have a
fully charged shot you can actually dive
down to the ink for about a second or
two pop up and let it go
it's good for when you need to
reposition but also it's really good for
sneak attacks and so as far as personal
recommendations go I absolutely love the
e-liter 4k it's the weapon with the
longest range in the entire game so
you're gonna be playing people from well
across the map now it's not available
until level 20
trust me it's worth the wait the next up
our slasher is the big buckets and now
slashes are powerful in terms of raw
inking power now they create a huge
puddle of ink wherever you toss them and
they're good for offense they can take
out any inkling with only two direct
hits but they can struggle against some
ranged weapons due to their slow rate of
fire as you'll be hitting the trigger
every time you want to toss a bucket of
ink at anyone and what you want to do
with sloshes is use the walls to your
advantage you can heave ink over ledges
over walls and with only two hits to
splat it's a pretty powerful tool now
since the regular slasher is actually
kind of a slow to fire weapon I would
actually go with the tri-slosher which
is actually a variant that has a greater
rate of fire and even though you can't
splat another player with only two hits
the inking capability is actually more
than make up for the reduced damage
output
it's got splat bombs and also the ink
armor which is a really good special and
so with that you've got a weapon that
will help cover ink on the ground help
do damage and also provide a really
great defensive option for your whole
team alright and finally we have
actually one of my new favorites the
splat lean and now this is a kind of
slow to charge slow to move weapon no
it's like a big Gatling gun that you
have to charge up but man does it have
some power like a fully Rev splat lean
will have some of the greatest fire rate
of any weapon in the game and it can
even rival some of the most powerful
shooters at least in terms of raw damage
per second most splat liens will
actually have a really good range as
well so what you want to do is usually
hang back
over everything up you know maybe hiding
behind a wall and then walking out as
you're starting to fire so anyone who
gets in the way will be immediately
splattered and you don't want to just
rush into the fray and hope you know
hope that you can charge up on time what
you want to do is use your range to your
advantage now see if you can climb up I
shoot ink into their territory and kind
of annoy them that way
and so one important thing to always
keep in mind when using a splat lean is
to try to remain in your own ink color
as often as possible spot leaders will
thrive in their own territory as it's
pretty easy to take out someone that's
just walking straight towards you and
you can take them out from a distance so
what you want to do is establish your
dominance make sure that they know that
they just can't approach you head-on but
look out for charges though usually
though out range you so don't be afraid
to hide mid shot you know you can rev up
all you want but once you have a charger
lined up we can see you you can dive
back down into the ink and just run away
one of the disadvantages with the
spoiling is that you'll have a harder
time consistently inking turf with it as
the shots kind of travel far so they'll
be a little bit more spread out than
your normal shooter so something like
the sprinkler sub-weapon or anything
else that can assist you in inking the
turf is always good to have so overall
what splat leans will you'll be doing
most of the time is pretty much backing
up the front line like you won't be out
threatening to push but you will be on
the sides taking out flankers making
sure people stay at a distance against
your team alright and that's it I hope
you guys enjoyed this lesson and again
there really isn't an answer to the
question what is the best weapon you
know each weapon will have its
advantages and disadvantages
what I advise doing is first find the
weapon that's right for you you know
look for one that complements your
playstyle like if you like going in hard
fast go for a shooter if you like
hanging back and picking off people from
a distance like a charger or a splatling
would be really good and so once you
found your weapon type go in try all the
different sub weapons customize your
gear to make sure it fits your playstyle
and see what works best for you that's
all I can really say about that the
weapons are so different in this game
and you're bound to find one that you
really really like alright guys if you
liked this video make sure to leave a
comment below telling me what your
favorite weapons are what your favorite
sub weapons specials weapon types if
you're a charger fan let me know I want
to hang out with you
brush fan stay away from me if you found
this video helpful please leave a like
or even consider subscribing to our
channel with helped me out a whole lot
so thanks for watching and I will see
you squids next time
[Music]